hi guys sci-fi recap here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a psychological
thriller movie from 2018 called greta
starring chloe grace moretz the film
starts in new york city where a young
waitress frances mccullen is going home
with a subway when she finds a black
handbag which belongs to greta hittig
at first she hesitates but then she
decides to bring the bag home
she lives with her best friend named
erica who suggests taking the money
inside the bag but she refuses
later they decide to watch a movie in
the cinema which makes francis emotional
as she used to go there with her mom who
had just passed away a year ago
her relationship with her father chris
is not very good as he has already moved
on and buries himself in work following
the address in the bag francis travels
to greta's house the next day to return
the bag
greta thanks her for returning the bag
and invites francis to have a drink
inside
in the house she hears some strange
pounding noises coming from a wall
behind the piano but greta claims that
it's her neighbor reconstructing
francis then discovers that greta's
husband kristoff has passed away and her
daughter nicola is in paris
the two women form a quick bond based
solely on their pain and loneliness
francis then suggests greta to adopt a
new puppy for support but greta refuses
as she is still hung up on her previous
dog
before leaving francis leaves her phone
number in case greta changes her mind
it doesn't take long as greta calls
francis to take her up on a dog the next
morning they decide to adopt an old dog
and named him morton
from here they become closer and spend
more time together
erica asks francis to go to a party with
her but she refuses and states that she
is having dinner with greta annoyed
erica then accuses her of using greta as
replacement for her mother which makes
francis furious francis goes over to
greta's home for dinner
their seemingly innocent friendship
takes a sinister turn when greta asks
francis to grab a candle in a cabinet
she opens the wrong one making a
startling discovery
multiple identical handbags with the
exact same contents inside every one of
them
one has a sticky note with the number of
a woman named samantha bale while the
other bag contains a sticky note written
with her own name on it meaning that
greta has been purposely leaving the bag
in the subway to lure people into her
life the young girl then becomes
uncomfortable with the dinner and asks
to leave the house immediately
hoping that greta will simply go away
francis isn't so lucky as greta begins
to terrorize her with abundant messages
but she manages to ignore the text the
old lady then shows up at the restaurant
where francis works forcing greta to
tell the truth about the handbags
finding and not wanting to be part of
the crazy game greta has planned
she also tells greta that she never
wants to see her again
greta continues to stop francis more
aggressively standing outside the
restaurant for hours and creepily
staring at her from across the street
feeling threatened she calls the police
but he refuses to arrest her she hasn't
shown any indication that she will
attack
greta also attempts to meet francis in a
subway but francis reacts fast and
manages to escape
things only get more frightening when
greta turns her stalking attention to
erica sending pictures of her at the
exact location to francis
francis then calls erica and urges her
to immediately get away from wherever
she is
the mad woman continues to send francis
pictures to show that she is getting
closer and closer to erica who somehow
doesn't see her despite the picture
being like right behind her
fortunately erica manages to outmaneuver
greta and spots the cab francis is in
she then joins her and they successfully
escape from greta
worried by the adopted dog safety
francis attempts to seek into the old
woman's house
as she digs through the trash for
anything she can find on her she
discovers that her daughter nicola is
not actually in paris she then tries to
get in touch with nicola later on
francis meets alexa hammond nicholas
ex-girlfriend who explains that nicola
has committed suicide four years earlier
and had never been to paris
she also states that greta is a very ill
woman and reveals that the old lady is
actually hungarian
things get worse when greta returns to
the restaurant who made a reservation
the lady insists that she only wants to
talk but later goes wild smashing the
wine glass and yelling that their
meeting is destiny and her mother had to
die for them to meet the crazy woman
flips over the table and starts
advancing towards francis
greta is then restrained by staff as the
police arrive and take the woman away
however francis discovers that greta has
been released the next day erica
suggests a plan to lie to greta by
staying with her father for a while
hoping that this would be enough for
greta to leave her alone she then agrees
with the plan and decides to meet greta
and tells her that she is going away for
a while
greta then gives her an uncomfortably
long hug
later francis is having a drink in her
home when she starts to feel dizzy
unfortunately the coffee had been
drugged and greta suddenly shows up
punishing francis for supposedly lying
about going away
greta drags the poor francis back to her
lovely gingerbread house locking her in
a toy box
apparently the kidnapping was just a
dream
frances wakes up and finds erica in the
apartment with her
she then tells francis to pack up
because her dad is already waiting for
her downstairs
she then goes to the elevator to leave
but suddenly the elevator appears to be
going lower than the bottom floor and
the walls start closing in
actually meeting erica and chris was a
dream
francis is really locked in a toy box
and she now really wakes up screaming to
be let out
greta grants her request
then grabs her phone and leaves her
again trapped in the room
the phone is used to make erica believe
that she is on vacation with her father
while also making chris think that she
is on vacation with erica
due to this francis is kept hostage by
greta for weeks with no one looking for
her
on one afternoon while they are making
cookies together francis finds an
opportunity and attempts to attack greta
by slamming a rolling pin down which
ends up severing her finger also
followed by a slam into her head
she runs to find an escape but all are
well locked sending her down to the
basement where she finds a bag
containing a body of dying samantha bale
greta then finds francis and suffocates
her until passed out greta then brings
her back to the room behind the piano
and ties her to the bed
chris goes to visit the girls in the
apartment and is welcomed by erica
at that moment they both realize that
something is not right
he then speaks to detective brian cody
to help find francis
cody pulls up files on greta revealing
that she used to be a nurse and
dismissed from misuse of anesthetics
cody finds greta's home and meets the
mad woman
she then invites her to go in and have a
chat
realizing that someone else is within
the house francis tries to make her
presence known by banging on the bed and
making the pendulum on the piano start
ticking
greta claims that the sound was made by
her dog and she goes upstairs to shut
the dog
exploring the house cody is very close
to finding the hidden room but greta
suddenly appears and injects sedatives
in his neck causing him paralyzed on the
floor
he attempts to shoot with his gun but
misses greta then grabs the gun and
shoots cody to death
she dumps his body into a bag adding
some chemicals to his face and throws
him to the basement
greta then shows up in the subway to
find her next victim
a young woman with curly brown hair
takes the bait and arrives at the house
to give back the bag
as they chat the pendulum starts ticking
again indicating that frances is making
sound again
greta then steps away for a moment to
shut the neighbor as she said to the new
girl and returns to have her coffee
suddenly she starts to feel disoriented
and falls off to the ground
surprisingly the woman then pulls off
her wig and reveals herself to be erica
having been waiting in the subway for a
while until she found the handbag
as greta faints francis continues
banging on the bed to help erica find
her position
erica manages to pull the piano back and
successfully freeze francis from her
agony
as erica tries to help her friend out
music starts playing indicating that
greta is still lurking around but as
francis steps out greta grabs her by the
throat and says that she was her
favorite one
greta then passes out
the girls then decide to place the mad
woman into the toy box and lock it with
an eiffel tower trinket
as they leave greta slowly starts
bumping the lid of the box slowly moving
the trinket out
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching